it's a market worth 7 billion euros
plans to regulate the production of
seeds has seen over 200 000 people
across europe sign a petition against it
but for these farmers in belgium
europe's legislative arm was being
stretched too far to the detriment of
innovation and biodiversity of small
producers
back at parliament it wasn't a vote to
adopt the proposal but to reject it
right
better protection for holiday makers who
book package deal holidays is on the way
after meps approved a draft report on
tuesday
plans include guaranteeing flights for
stranded passengers better information
but one of the most important changes
was quite simple it was necessary to
clear up the rules because the old
regulation didn't know the internet
the online booking
over 28 000 people killed and 1.5
million injured in car accidents
improved road safety was given a boost
after meps voted to adopt a new e-call
in-car system from next year all new
cars and member states will be fitted
with a sim card that in the event of an
accident we'll call 112 the eu emergency
hotline letting emergency services know
where you are and come to your aid but
what if the accident isn't serious then
what so once the accident happens
the emergency service the psap so-called
the public safety answering points gets
packed
to the to the car to ask what what
happened is it necessary that we come is
it a serious is it a serious accident